my friends how do you not understand
that you have to produce a hundred
pieces of content a day how do you not
understand that every day that you wake
up whether for yourself or for your
business or your ambition or your
organization how do you not understand
that you should be putting out 50 to 100
pieces of content a day YouTube what's
up so so grateful that you clicked and
you're about to watch a new youtube
video but before you do - one two nine
thirty one five seven three one that is
my texting community platform doing a
lot of one-on-one engagement in there
and also access opportunity first looks
in that environment - one two nine
thirty one five seven three one join it
now and now to the video you've been
wanting to watch you got your
perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning so thank you so much for
having me a couple different things I
want to talk about this morning most of
all when I think about the makeup of the
room and when you speak and you have a
general audience it's so important to
find the thing that most connects
everybody in the room and for me that
thing very much is attention if you
really understand what everybody here is
trying to accomplish its attention we're
we're very much in a place where if
you're unable to get the attention of
the end consumer of the person you're
trying to reach you absolutely have no
chance of actually accomplishing the
goal at hand if you're an entrepreneur
if you're a university professor if
you're in the b2b space if you're a
Content producer if your startup an
executive everybody here has to focus on
actually getting the attention of the
end consumer and then starting to create
context for that goal the reason I spend
so much time thinking about social media
over the last decade is because way back
when when this came out and for the beat
how many people here by show of hands
are over 40 years old raise your hand
thank you under 30 okay so for you
youngsters in here when this came out
for all of us over 40 I think a lot of
you can remember that there was a lot of
debate on how expensive it was how many
people here had a blackberry in their
life raise your hands
hold them up high I want the kids to
look at all these people
haier keep those lights on if you don't
mind I like seeing the faces you could
put them down
every person that just raised their
hands when the iPhone came out said I'm
not getting an iPhone I can't feel the
buttons on the phone that was the big
debate the big debate the reason people
told me that they would not get this is
because they liked the fact that they
got used to the BlackBerry and they
could type quickly without looking what
I understood was this was an operating
system that this was connected to the
single most important invention maybe in
the human race or at least up to this
point which is called the Internet
everybody in this room including myself
is grossly under estimating the impact
of the internet on the human race and so
you know the internet started gaining
real traction on the consumer level in
the mid 90s late 90s depending on what
market you're in but the reality is for
me the thing that I really want to
accomplish today is get every person
from that corner to that corner back to
understand that it is highly likely
highly likely that the breakthrough or
the advancement or the growth that
you're looking for comes at the expense
of you understanding that you're
actually a media company and not what
else you do I believe that everybody
will realize over the next decade that
almost everything in our society is
being commoditized except the ability to
communicate that when you think about
what you do the product you sell and
your ability to communicate it is
fundamentally what's left the internet
will become the wholesaler the
distributor the middle there used to be
enormous value in the middle the people
that had the middle controlled
everything the families or entrepreneurs
or media companies that shot satellites
into space or owned the printing press
or radio stations they had control they
distribute
distribution was where the leverage was
because if they didn't pick you you
weren't able to see the day of light
they were able to keep the value today
this is the distribution today the value
chain to making something happen whether
that is to become the President of
Mexico or to sell sneakers the value
chain of your ability to leverage this
distribution is the punchline
I believe that no different than taking
care of your physical health to live
longer or knowing how to balance your
checkbook is important to keep your
business alive that the new requirement
of the next decade is the ability for
you to be a communications executor that
no longer no longer are we in a place
where that can be outsourced or
misunderstood many of us in this
audience as I look around grew up in a
world where the media had 100% control
of the narrative outside of spending a
lot of money in advertising to be able
to communicate you know given the way
the world's working I value especially
because I was born in the Soviet Union I
valued journalism and the media greater
than ever not less however that does not
take out of the equation the fact that
every single person here whether through
LinkedIn a podcast Facebook Twitter
Instagram whatsapp has the ability to
become their communicator and so for me
it's been very fascinating it's been
fascinating to watch how many businesses
are getting disrupted how many
organizations institutions are getting
disrupted and yet I would argue that it
is highly unlikely that what I just
talked about for the last ten minutes is
something that is so profound for this
room I would argue what I just spoke
about for the last 10 minutes is
borderline common sense or just
reaffirmation of something you
absolutely
they already know the important part of
this conversation this keynote is not
what I just framed up that that is not
even a debatable aspect the question is
if you agree and understand everything
that I just talked about why are you not
communicating five to fifty five times a
day my question this room is I don't
think I dropped any remarkable knowledge
in the last 10 minutes my question is
why am i making at the scale that I'm
making every day why are the people that
are advancing culturally in business in
every arena are the ones who are
actually making content and why are you
and your organization not why are you
still stuck in a world of politics and
subjectiveness internally to push out
content why are you still in a world
where you value the production quality
as quality not the message that it's
being delivered in why are you willing
to live your life as an individual or an
organization based on a communications
and media landscape that no longer
exists ever thank you mom
but friends this is a super interesting
talk I'm even feeling it in my own head
I'm like talking to myself as I'm
talking I'm like this is remarkable this
is actually remarkable what what I'm
talking about is uncomfortably basic the
Internet has changed the way we
communicated why aren't you using it
thank you very much Mexico see it like
that's literally that's literally the
talk but this this is what how many
people here are consume my content raise
your hands
I'm just curious thank you so and how
many of those hands have been consuming
for longer than three years by show of
hands thank you
smaller the people that just raised
their hands if they're sitting next to
you you will tell you that over the last
three years I've become less tactical
and have started talking more about
parenting and and patience and more
mindset because I am so uncomfortable
with the first ten minutes of this talk
my friends how do you not understand
that you have to produce a hundred
pieces of content a day how do you not
understand that every day that you wake
up whether for yourself or for your
business or your ambition or your
organization how do you not understand
that you should be putting out 50 to 100
pieces of content a day 10 tweets 15
posts on LinkedIn and you tend and
LinkedIn excuse me
a podcast a blog like what's the
conversation here nobody has leverage
over you anymore this is the
distribution this is it this and the 8
to 10 websites that work in your market
does Mexico have different thing
dynamics than the u.s. of course does
whatsapp have more equity here than does
in the US Shore is is tik-tok bigger
right now in the u.s. southern right
sure but it's still the same game I'm
agnostic I don't care if you want to
talk about Telegraph or whatsapp
Facebook or Instagram it's still the
same game it is a pipe on top of the
Internet and you need to figure out how
to talk on it when I say talk there's
only three things it's so basic
the written word audio and video it's
been like this for a long time
you could be in the newspaper business
in the radio business or the television
business and all of it is here and you
don't have to pay for distribution let
me say that one more time I'm 44 in a
week and what even at my young of an age
I remember a day and age when I ran a
business where I had to pay a lot of
money to the New York Times I had to pay
a lot of money to the post office to
send direct mail I had to pay a lot of
money to the local radio station to have
a host read my ad I had a petty I had to
pay a lot of money for the gatekeeper of
awareness to let me have a chance to
talk to you I don't pay anything now now
I don't pay anything for the
distribution I pay for people creating
content
d-roc where you at there you go dear ox
not free
he might think it's a good deal I do too
I think he'll win in the end but
nonetheless the the shift of economics
has changed
think about how more exciting it is for
all of us in this room that our cost to
reach our customer whether it be to be
whether 80 years old
whether 16 years old whether it be to
see our cost is now an internal cost not
an external cost not to mention that the
amount of talent that is being created
at the 13 to 22 year old level and
currently sits in the 20 to 30 year old
level of people that know how to create
is remarkable there is an extraordinary
amount of 25 year olds on earth today
that would much rather get paid minimum
legal wage in their society to videotape
and make content for YouTube and
Instagram than they would to make double
that salary doing something they don't
love that is the mindset of the
Millennial user that is an incredible
relationship that is an opportunity both
for business and that individual my
friends there are so many conversations
in our system that have nothing to do
with the actual realities of our game
the actual realities of our game life is
that we have transcended into a new era
where everybody in this room has to
think of themselves like a journalist
like a movie producer like a radio host
and that is a requirement for the last
decade that I've been screaming on
stages all over the world it has been a
luxury let me say this very carefully I
want everybody to pay attention this is
no different than in 1995 to 2003 when I
was speaking in much smaller places in
New Jersey when I would say having a
website was a luxury in 1997 it became a
requirement in 2005 my friends
time of you being able to not produce
content on the 10 social networks or
content platforms of our society the
time of that being a luxury is going
away and we are going into the decade of
where it is a requirement this is very
important to me and I'm desperately
trying to get it through to everybody
because I don't know what other way to
curse or what other way to make a
Content piece or what clever thing to do
what quote to put over a picture of me
on a stage I'm running out of different
ways to say the same thing and here it
is one more time for the kids in the
back unless you tomorrow understand that
whatever your ambition is whatever you
want to happen professionally and
personally unless you understand the
requirement is to produce as much
content as possible you will be out
maneuvered by somebody else what what
I'm seeing that's fascinating to me is
the following as many of you know for a
decade but definitely for a half a
decade I've been screaming about the
opportunities of social networks over
the last year we're starting to start to
see the cracks of the biggest companies
in the world starting to consider to
move their budgets into this world some
are pulling out because they don't like
the politics of Facebook others pulling
in in very basic data not opinion the
cost of Facebook ads have gone up not
down this is because people realize it's
actually working I can stand here today
and tell everybody here that if they
have a how many people here are in the
b2c business actually selling to end
consumers just raise your hands for
every hand that just went up I can tell
you right now in Mexico right this
second for customers 18 to 45
on the consumer lens that Instagram
story adds so the ads and story is not
in the main theme are so uncomfortably
underpriced that the two and three
dollars CPM to reach a thousand Mexican
citizens in a targeting capability is so
unfathomable that if you actually make
twenty five and fifty pieces of content
for the ad not one because you know
you're targeting 26 to 32 year-old
females in Mexico City who are
interested in soft drinks or what have
you that the upside is extraordinary I
can leave that right now actively I can
leave tackling that the pre-roll ads on
YouTube in this country when you factor
in the search queries on Google are some
of the best video ad content in the
world
that there is so much consumption of
YouTube in this country and so few
taking advantage of the pre-roll ads
that your ability to build awareness not
conversion sales but awareness brand
marketing not selling in pre-roll
YouTube form is unprecedented
unprecedented I'm just trying to
convince somebody to test it to do it we
sit around all day and it's very
important for everybody in this room to
figure this out you have to understand
are you a Salesman or you a marketer and
both are okay but the problem for so
many people is they get confused and
think they're doing marketing when
they're actually doing sales and it's
super important how many people here are
entrepreneurs raise your hands so for me
this which is an enormous percentage of
this room this is where this gets very
important everything I'm talking about
compounds in importance for
entrepreneurs because how many
more time and can you put the lights on
how many people are entrepreneurs raise
your hands hold them up the amount of
time thank you
the amount of time that the hands that
just went up that is spent I'm trying to
figure out how to get fundraising is
devastating we are living through the
golden era of entrepreneurs who have
become incapable of building practical
businesses without the notion of raising
an enormous amount of capital for all
the hands that just went up I would wish
for you if you had your
great-grandparents or grandparents that
actually were entrepreneurs to for you
to have a conversation with them about
how you're thinking about executing your
business versus how they did we are
living in a world where so many people
now spend all their time thinking about
how and especially when you're not in
America and even in America when you're
not in Silicon Valley there are
uncomfortable amounts of hours in this
room of people in meetings crying about
the fact that it's hard to raise capital
it should be hard to raise capital like
this notion of entitlement that because
you have a [ __ ] idea that you deserve
money for it to do it is laughable it is
a disease in America it is a disease in
Asia it is a disease in Latin America
the notion that you have to raise
capital to start I started vaynermedia
by starting the company in a conference
room of another company so I didn't have
to pay rent and I worked for a couple
weeks to find somebody to pay me for a
project and I took that money and that's
how I hired our first employee you can
build a business without raising capital
Thanks because it's real
my friends will be living through the
greatest era a fake entrepreneurship
right now it's gotten so cool that
everybody wants to be one and it scares
me listen I was one I'm benefiting from
the popularity of entrepreneurship that
doesn't mean that I don't want to talk
about all the perils when you try to be
an entrepreneur when you're not I want
to remind this room that the 17th
employee at Facebook made a lot more
money than 99.99999%
of entrepreneurs entrepreneurship on a
pedestal is a very dangerous game it's
extremely lonely it's extremely
difficult and the reality is to be a
true entrepreneur that's able to
navigate successfully you have to be in
a position where you have a great
relationship with the judgment people
struggle with judgment especially from
their friends and family
judgment is the poison of our society
and it is accelerated where you have
nowhere to hide
how many how many people here are
employees you work somewhere raise your
hand raise them don't worry raise some
high for everybody who just raise your
hand I think being an employee is
phenomenal and I'll tell you why the
best part of being an employee is you
always have somebody else to blame one
of the reasons I know that we're living
through the greatest year of
entrepreneurship is because I get
hundreds and thousands of dm's and
messages and I have meetings with
entrepreneurs every day and I am
fascinated with their ability to spend
the majority of our time together
complaining or painting of picture of
other people within their organization
being at fault for their lack of success
entrepreneurs one more time I apologize
hands in the air let me give you my best
hit bit before I leave 100% of the
problems with your company is 100% your
fault
when I tell you that there are 500
problems at vaynermedia that I can think
of right now I can do that right now
they're all my fault
because the people that are running
those situations I hired them they may
suck but it's my responsibility to fire
them and replace them I'm also the one
that hired them
or I hired the person that hired them if
you raised your hand and you're an
entrepreneur I promise you the quickest
way to happiness and success is 100%
blind accountability it's not fun you
know earlier I was with a group of
people we got into a conversation around
parenting and Technology everybody wants
to blame Facebook and Instagram and cell
phones because they don't want to be
accountable for the fact that they have
created children with no self esteem and
are 100% entitled it's a lot more fun to
blame something else than it is to blame
yourselves it's a lot more fun for you
to sit around a dinner table and blame
Mexico's government for your lack of
success not you my friends life is very
basic there's always something you know
as I'm sure you know there's a lot of
tension politically within the US and
there's a lot of people complaining and
worried and upset and there's plenty to
fix we have many shortcomings but let me
promise you this in the globe the eight
billion of us seven point seven billion
of us there's never been a better time
to be alive Mary your startup well I
need to know what it is
well you send me an email and I'll read
it you got it so before that lovely lady
just interrupted my flow which leads to
almost guaranteed no shot of marrying
her startup the point I'm trying to make
is very simple we are not living through
the World War II era we are not living
through the Black Plague people like
Gary I can't raise money for my startup
I'm like you know what's worse than that
the Holocaust you know as somebody who
loves history especially last 100 years
in the world there is so much that has
happened in this great country in the
last hundred years that has been far
more difficult climates to execute your
entrepreneurial dream than the one that
you're sitting in right now fluffy in a
conference listening to me talk my
friends
we need to eliminate excuses excuses are
quite popular excuses are fun and easy
excuses come when actual macro
prosperity is actually happening and so
I really spend a lot more time now
thinking about perspective than I do
around a lot of other things that are
tactical tactically I can sit here and
I'm gonna actually sit here cuz I'm in
the mood right now I'm getting a little
serious here I can sit here tactically
and say to you listen my entire career
has been built on the fact that I'm very
good at understanding where organic
reach to the end consumer change my mind
where organic reach to the end consumer
is very underpriced let me explain I was
smart enough intuitive enough gifted
with the ability to understand people
enough whatever you want to call it to
understand in 1995 that the internet was
not a fad and that people would use it
and so instead of opening a second
liquor store for my family business I
launched a website that was considered
crazy that worked I also understand
in 1997 that people would read email how
many people here had email in 1999 raise
your hands
stand up stand up stand up if you had
email in 1999 please don't be lazy I
just want the room to see this okay
first let's clap it up for these
dinosaurs I'm one state state please
please I want people to see this put the
lights on please stand if you had to
email if you're being lazy please stand
a few an email in 1999 I want to see the
numbers thank you by the people standing
by a show of hands or shake your head
cuz I want everybody see this do you
remember in 1999 when we would get an
email do you remember that we read every
[ __ ] word of every email recall that
you can sit thank you that that my
friends who have been sitting that's
what I was good at I understood in 1999
that people had email that it was free
to send an email and that they read it
and that is why I started an email
newsletter instead of a paper newsletter
which I wish you understood in 1999 was
crazy
in 1999 starting an email newsletter
instead of a printed newsletter would be
like somebody here who's in financial
services starting a tik-tok account
tomorrow it made no sense to people I
also knew that in 2001 or two I don't
recall that Google Adwords and Google
search organic was underpriced
that I thought Google would defeat Yahoo
that people would search and if you
typed in Cabernet or Bordeaux that it
was good for my store to show up I had
no money my dad had a local liquor store
that was doing 3 million dollars a year
almost 4 on 10% gross profit 400,000
gross
before expenses of employees and water
and rent no money my first year
marketing budget was less than $30,000
and really it was zero but I had to find
it somewhere else my career has been
predicated on underpriced attention
that's why I was first on YouTube that's
why I was earliest on Twitter and
Facebook finally by the time I was 32 33
I got smart and started investing in the
companies not just using it but I can
sit here today because I still have this
talent and I'm still in the dirt the
reason I run vaynermedia is I want to be
in the dirt when you're in the dirt you
know what's going on when you're in the
clouds when you're in an ivory tower you
do not I stay in the dirt which allows
me on this morning on November 7th 2019
with all the success and opportunity I
have I can deliver to this room the
tactical advice that what built me email
website Google search YouTube Facebook
is 100% happening right now on LinkedIn
and tick-tock 100% you could have no
profile on either one of those accounts
go write an article on LinkedIn four
sentences five sentences that brings
value not as a commercial for your
business and by the time you wake up the
next morning thirty ninety four hundred
people that have never heard of you have
now heard of you and half of them 80% of
them agree with you and one of them or
two of them is intrigued by you I just
don't understand especially for all the
hands that went up early when I say this
every day how many of them still don't
make content this leads to insecurity
this leads into this stuff when people
say Gary I want more tactics from you're
like very easy with tactics just watch
everything I'm doing and do that too I
mean it I'm not throwing around my cell
number in America for text numbers for
my health or cuz I think it's funny I'm
doing it because I believe that we're in
the early stages of social medias macro
decline
and that I want the first party data of
having my end-users phone number so I
can talk to them directly because I
don't like that I have 7 million
followers on Instagram but when I hit
post a small fraction of those 7 million
people see it now I'm not a crybaby like
everybody else that's mad that the
organic reaches down cuz I'm very aware
that it is free watching remember
Facebook a couple years ago when you
would post on your page and the numbers
went down and everybody was crying and
mad at sucks I kept trying to remind
everybody I'm like it's free Instagram
does not charge you YouTube does not
charge you to go on the platform and
distribution television print radio
outdoor billboards charge you this is
free for distribution this will be the
next decade of communication warfare we
will separate as organizations as people
as the people that are the haves versus
the have-nots many of you over the next
decade will fire or restructure your
businesses to bring in journalists
videographers designers cartoonist
animators you will start slowly but
surely understanding how true what I'm
saying is this is going to be a
communication warfare you will also
bring in math oriented individuals that
understand how to navigate organic and
paid distribution in whatever the
Facebook's and linkedin's and tic TOCs
are of a decade of today whether they're
all there or none of them are there I
could care less in a weird way I almost
prefer that tomorrow every social
network and content platform disappeared
off the face of the earth because then
everybody would be stunned and where do
you go and my greatest skill is finding
where the attention is and I believe
that I could gather the most whether
that is going back to
prynt going back to radio I could care
less tactical I believe that 90% of this
room should start a podcast I believe
that 90% of this room should start a
podcast I believe that over the next
decade and start and even now that the
rise of audio consumption has exploded
by chopin's sorry to the lighting people
by show of hands how many people here
now listen to at least one podcast at
least once a week raise your hands raise
it high people in the front look at how
staggering this number is put him down
of the people that just raised their
hand how many of you listened to a
podcast at least once a week five years
ago raise your hand look around what I
just showed you by a show of hands thank
you what I just showed you by a show of
hands is what I do for a living I day
trade attention when I wrote crushing it
this book up here which is my last book
in the yellow if you can see it up there
I have the logos of the platforms that I
talked about Instagram snapchat Facebook
Twitter podcasting YouTube this was my
book of the contemporary places to
execute what I just talked about this is
18 months old
not LinkedIn nor tik-tok show up on that
book yet it has been the far majority of
what I've talked to you about this
morning
in 18 months I come back here or come
out with another book or give another
keynote I may not even utter the words
LinkedIn or tick-tock the skill set that
is required going forward for any
business in a communications warfare is
the ability to understand where the
attention is and be able to produce
content for it this single biggest
reason most of you will not be able to
go back home
and execute on the model that I just
told you about the single reason is
because of judgment of the content
itself many of you do not go on video
because you're insecure of the way you
look on video that's okay with me
that's human nature what is not
acceptable for me is for you not to
challenge yourself to figure out what
kind of communicator you actually are
are you capable of writing are you
capable of taking your phone hitting the
memos and just talking for six minutes
and posting that are you capable of
video I'm an intuitive communicator
operator had I been a hardcore quant
analytical operator I would be sitting
here this morning showing you slides
showing you incredible math and charts
completely affirming what I'm talking
about when you just look at the sheer
consumption that we as human beings now
take into content because of this you
used to not be able to watch television
when you were on the bus you had to get
home and watch it my friends what has
happened in our lives is a very big deal
when we are long gone
and it is 500 years from now I promise
you many will look back to this 50 years
as a turning point in the human race the
internet the inevitability of the
blockchain and many other technologies
is a very substantial deal it is now
executing and affecting your business
please please please please hear me loud
and clear this morning and understanding
that this is very basic this is no
different than if I was giving a keynote
this morning about health if I was
talking about physical health
I would be talking about eating better
and working out you want to get into
better shape I have the secret everyone
stop eating [ __ ] and workout every
morning yet an incredible amount of
people here continue to look for some
magic formula of apple juice vinegar
some [ __ ] waste thing that you wear
24 hours a day that [ __ ] shrinks your
[ __ ] of plastic surgery of doctors of
some miraculous shortcut to not put in
the work that is what I'm speaking about
today in the form of entrepreneurship
and business it has become unbelievably
clear very clear there is your product
your product the thing you sell yourself
your time your product and then nothing
anymore in the middle which used to be
the whole game stores networks
wholesalers media companies the middle
that used to be the game this is not the
game your product and your ability to
tell me about it the end and until you
become religious about those two you
will become vulnerable the first about
your product that's on you I don't know
what how good of a lawyer you are I
don't know how good of a Mason you are I
don't know how good of a flower shop
steel manufacturer educator I don't know
you've got to work on your craft but I
promise you this this part right here
this port is very interesting to me I'll
tell you why if I could have you better
at one of those two things I would have
you better at this because the quality
of something is
active the ability to communicate and
make one believe of its quality is the
way it gets played out in results until
everybody takes a big step back and
realizes that communication on cell
phones today and more importantly and
this is why let me get to the punchline
let me tell you why I only care about
you building brand in the next decade we
will see the emergence of a technology
that I think is potentially unbelievably
disruptive and that is voice devices in
our homes that are a I assisted Google
home Apple pod Amazon Alexa many other
companies that are gonna pop up in other
parts of the world that are gonna
compete I believe that there is a
naivete and a misunderstanding of how
potentially powerful these devices are
everything that has worked for me over
the last twenty years has been grounded
in my unbelievable belief that you
choose convenience and speed almost over
anything else in the world that while
mainstream media continues to try to
tell us that we care about privacy I
watch you every day give up privacy for
convenience if I needed to go find a
wonderful place to eat right now 15
years ago with none of your help I would
have to go look at a print product a
Yellow Pages like product a magazine
that says best restaurants in Monterey
it would take me a long time today I can
choose this and within three to four
minutes be in the game in a half a
decade to a decade I can say Alexa
what's the best restaurant in Monterey
and get the answer like this
I can get my babysitter I can book my
calendar invite I can make every
decision with an A I assisted voice
device if you are in the food business
and you're in the pizza business and
you're the best at Google and you show
up first and you're posting remarkable
photos on the Instagram about your pizza
and all those things that's very very
nice however unless you are capable of
building a brand that comes out of my
mouth in a decade
when I say Google send me a pizza you're
in deep trouble because now Google
becomes the Tollbooth Google decides
what Pizza I'm getting either a the
pizza company that Google owns or B the
pizza company that spends the most money
for the referral that they won't even be
able to afford based on their profit
margin it will not be me typing in pizza
and choosing because you bought ads or
you have the best copy brand in a voice
world is the only thing left if you have
not started the process of building your
personal brand or the brand of your
organization you are going to be
uncomfortably vulnerable in the next
decade or two s advancements I want to
remind this room as a parting shot that
everything we talked about today from
smart phones to social networks to
Netflix to everything Uber's and on and
on and on everything we talked about did
not exist fifteen years ago did not
exist if you think a lot has happened
since then - now wait do you see what
happens over the next 15 years because
the stack of technology is in place for
far quicker advancement unless you are
storytelling and producing content that
is either educational or entertaining
either bringing P
the ability to escape their normal life
which is why they will consume it or
educate and be a utility you will be
squeezed out today today needs to be the
day that you stop thinking about it and
debating it today must become the day
that you are in the singular business of
ideas of what you want to say and
actually making it my friends if you are
not putting out ten twenty thirty
seventy pieces of content a day you have
started the process to being completely
irrelevant thank you thank you thank you
thank you